bedrohlich nah ziehen die rauchwolken
richtung platz mehr hektik bricht aus
träumen sie den strand sofort die sie
von hier weg
die waldbrände an der südfranzösischen
atlantikküste wüten seit einer woche mit
einer wucht die alle überrascht hat
sofort evakuieren mehr als 34.000
menschen müssen hals über kopf fliehen
anwohner und urlauber ihre bleibe
verlassen
zuflucht finden sie in dieser messe
halle auch marcelo und linda aus
eberswalde sind hier gestrandet zählt
fahrräder und vieles mehr müssen sie
zurücklassen während ihre kinder in der
bauecke spielen überlegen die beiden nun
wie es weitergehen soll marcel erzählt
von der nacht als die flammen kamen
wir sind nach sonnenuntergang auf die
bühne gegangen und da schlugen die
flammen meterhoch
wir haben uns dann irgendwie doch zur
ruhe gelegt ein zelt gelegt und morgens
um drei
halb vier sind die quasi dann mit
mikrofonen und taschenlampe die sekte
security personal
durch durch das areal gelaufen und haben
sofort gesagt feuer kommt fire is coming
sofort weg
die urlauber fliehen die retter reisen
an
das feuer bricht wieder aus wir brauchen
die komplette einheit
bin waffe von der pariser feuerwehr
unterstützt den kampf gegen die flammen
aus ganz frankreich sind kollegen in die
region abkommandiert worden
das feuer hat uns umzingelt wir können
nichts mehr sehen
beißender rauch und das
undurchdringliche unterholz erschweren
die löscharbeiten
es gibt hier keine feuer schneisen wie
sonst so oft in waldbrand gefährdeten
gebieten
los halte ich nach rechts
wir kommen hier mit dem wagen nicht
weiter das risiko ist zu groß
was kann dann passiere
wenn wir da rein fahren wird uns der
rückweg abgeschnitten
dieser brand sei wie ein pulverfass harz
und zapfen der pinien wirken wie
brandbeschleuniger
es ist alles so trocken hier in der
kollege aus dem hinteren fahrzeug waren
über funk
fahrt nicht zu tief rein jungs das team
aus paris muss zusammenbleiben sie
stützen einander kämpfen unermüdlich
gegen die flammen
bis zur erschöpfung nach wenigen stunden
schlaf geht es weiter
pausenlos koordiniert unterdessen das
krisenteam die einsätze der gut 2000
feuerwehrleute
es gibt nicht den einen brand es sind
mehrere luft und boden sind extrem heiß
bei der trockenheit genügt ein funke und
ein neues feuer ist entfacht
es ist heiß es hat ewig nicht geregnet
ich kann nicht verstehen dass die leute
immer noch picknick und lagerfeuer
machen oder grillen darüber qcv sie
rauchen und werfen ihre kippen in die
landschaft das ist erschreckend neun von
zehn bränden werden durch menschliches
fehlverhalten ausgelöst und das kann
einfach nicht wahr sein das ist
unglaublich
im hinterland der küste sind bereits
mehr als 20.000 hektar wald zerstört
eine fläche zweimal so groß wie paris
das feuer breitet sich wie ein krake aus
über mehrere arme wechselnde winde
treiben es in alle himmelsrichtungen
wie schnell schnell es ist auf die
felder übergesprungen am boden bericht
immer wieder panik aus landwirte
versuchen die flammen fernzuhalten
wollen verhindern dass sie über die
straße gelangen thierry karriere hängt
ständig am telefon hat nachbarn und
kollegen zusammengetrommelt ich habe
ihnen gesagt sie sollen wässern damit es
hier nicht auch noch zu brennen anfängt
die dürre die flammen so etwas hat er
noch nie erlebt seit dem ausbruch
kämpfen wir tag und nacht manchmal
gelingt es uns einfach nicht dass vorher
zu besiegen das ist schlimm aber wir
müssen weiter stark sein
für die fünf campingplätze die direkt an
der berühmten
pilar liegen konnte die feuerwehr nichts
mehr tun rezeption kiosk bungalows
verbrannt verzweifelt die betreiber der
ferienanlagen die sommersaison gerade
erst begonnen ist der feuersbrunst zum
opfer gefallen
das ist die apokalypse ich hätte mir das
nie vorstellen können ich hatte die
ganze zeit gehofft dass das feuer vorher
gestoppt
auch der platz auf dem die familie aus
eberswalde gekämpft hat ist zerstört
kurz bevor alles verbrannte durfte
marcel noch einmal für eine viertel
stunde zurück die restlichen sachen
holen
ja wir hatten wenig zeit gehabt die
leute standard gibt gas
ich war 14 uhr die fahrräder der kinder
reingepackt hinten auf dem bett sieht
man dann noch das vorzelt und die
matratze vorne so ein bisschen
kühlschrank also das musste alles ganz
ganz schnell gehen der kofferraum hinten
ist voll für ihn und mehr als 6000
kämpfer endet der urlaub in den dünen
abrupt manch einer kehrt nach hause
zurück andere ziehen weiter die
brandkatastrophe stimmt macht
nachdenklich mit einem mal ist der
klimawandel ganz nah gekommen
man das mit den jahren zuvor vergleicht
dann sieht man veränderungen wenn man
durchs land fährt und die
sonnenblumenfelder beobachtet entstehen
die nicht mannshoch sondern vielleicht
bis zum bauchnabel bis zur hüfte also
man merkt dass sich etwas verändert ich
bin ganz ehrlich dieses erlebte jetzt
das erlebte jetzt macht etwas mit mit
einem mit dem bewusstsein sie sprechen
hier von einem jahrhundert feuer die
menschen an der atlantikküste ein feuer
das sie nun langsam in den griff
bekommen doch die spuren bleiben auch
über diesen extrem sommer hinaus